[Musique]
bonjour à tous je ne doute pas que vous
avez reconnu la ville dont on va parler
aujourd'hui et en cours l'une des 12
communes de SaintQuentin en neline situé
au centre du département des ivin la
commune devient ville nouvelle dans les
années 70
1970 et elle accueille aujourd'hui près
de 25000 habitants alors un passé
historique et des lieux emblimatiques
des personnes à rencontrer je vous
propose qu'on aille visiter cette ville
de manière non exhaustive bien
sûr la commune a gardé deux lieux de son
passé l'église romane Saint-Méard datant
du 12e siècle mais aussi la commanderie
des Templiers bâtiment historique
formant de jeunes moin à l'art de la
chevalerie bonjour Luce bonjour alors si
je commence en disant la Commanderie les
Templiers de la ville Dieu les morp pas
est-ce que j'ai faux non vous avez tout
à fait raison cette commanderie était
sur le territoire de la châellen de
morpa qui était une très importante
Châtel n au Moyen-âge et c'est pour ça
qu'on indique la la l'emplacement
géographique parce que le nom de
villeedieu est un nom extrêmement
courant pour une commanderie à l'époque
la Casa dei en latin la maison de Dieu
c'est vraiment une dénomé ation très
commune donc on précise à côté de quelle
ville importante on la trouve parfois
aussi mentionnée comme commanderie de la
ville dieeu de trappe elle est fondée en
quelle année alors elle est fondée on
sait pas exactement en quelle année mais
a priori entre 1149 et 1181 puisqu'on
sait qu'à cette époque là un seigneur
alors de Chevreuse là cette fois-ci au
sud mais qui est aussi seigneur de morpa
donne une maison à situer à la ville
Dieu les morpas donc ce serait la
fondation de cette commanderie et ce
Seigneur là duc de Chevreuse de 1149 à
1181 alors on voit qu'il y a une
chapelle on en dira un petit mot après
ce qui marque aussi c'est la différence
de bâtiment qu'est-ce qui se passait ici
lors de sa fondation lors de sa
fondation c'est un lieu qui est destiné
à accueillir des chevaliers des moines
chevaliers c'est-à-dire des gens qui
appartiennent à l'ordre des Templiers
alors on dit l'ordre des pauvres
combattants du Christ et du Temple de
Salomon he c'est le nom complet les
Templiers et ici c'est une une
commanderie templière c'est-à-dire un
lieu destiné à la formation des
chevaliers soldats des moines soldats
mais aussi à gagner vraiment de l'argent
he des biens en nature et en en argent
pour financer les croisades en Orient
puisque'à l'époque on est en pleine
croisade en Terre sainte et c'est ce
genre de lieu est destiné à financer ces
croisades et c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi dès le départ une exploitation
agricole donc des bâtiments liés au
culte hein comme la chapelle des
bâtiments pour euh loger les moines
c'est le cas par exemple du bâtiment des
gardes et puis des lieux pour
l'exploitation agricole le bâtiment
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de Bièvre et
de Chevreuse oui il a eu différentes
vies c'était aussi un lieu de culture et
de loisirs de l'agglomération de C anine
et on peut la visiter on peut se balader
dans le dans la cour on va dire si on
peut dire ce motl on peut se balader
dans la dans la cour et voir les
différents bâtiments autour de la mar
centrale he puisque c'était une une
ferme à cour fermé autour de cette Mar
elle est ouverte tous les jours on peut
s'y promener il y a juste derrière la
coulée verte donc qui permet de faire
des promenades des Choues promenad on
l'a mentionné plusieurs fois je P qu'on
se termine sur la la chapelle
particulière tout à fait particulière il
y en a assez peu de conservé finalement
ce qu'elles ont de particulière ces
chapelles templières c'est qu'elles sont
toutes faites sur le même plan elles ont
toutes à peu près les mêmes dimensions à
une seule nef assez simple on fait pas
trop de décor chez les Templiers comme
chez les cisterciers en général elle a
particulier qu'elle a une tour
octogonale ce qui est assez rare
on dit que ce serait parce que c une
chapelle qui permettait des ordinations
de chevaliers d'où cette tour octogonale
et puis elle a un chevet qui est
octogonal lui aussi qui n'est pas plat
alors que la plupart des chapelles
templières ont un chevet plat elle a des
dimensions aussi assez assez grandes la
plupart des des chapelles de cette
époque sont plus
petites sans doute parce qu'elle a elle
a accueilli des cérémonies importante
d'ordination de de moine soldat et elle
est inscrite au Monument Historique tire
des historique qui ce qui a permis de la
protéger même si elle a subi les affres
du temps puisque elle a perdu elle a été
transformée en grange quand c'était une
ferme elle avait perdu ses vitrux on
avait baissé son sol qu'on a dû
restaurer les vitrux également pour
pouvoir aujourd'hui offrir la chapelle
telle qu'elle était au moment
probablement des des Chevaliers
[Musique]
Templiers
retour au centre-ville dans le quartier
des 7 mars l'un des tout premiers à
sortir de terre il y a maintenant plus
de 40 ans lors de la création de la
ville nouvelle de saanttin en Evelin il
a été inauguré en 1975 mairie cinéma
médiathèque salle de spectacle et
commerce et dans ce quartier une odeur
ne peut que vous attirer celle du four
et des pizzas de la dolce vita ce
restaurant fondé dans les années 80 il
est midi j'ai un peu faim allant
découvrir leur
[Musique]
cartte
bonjour Angela vous êtes la cogérante du
restaurant en quelques mots c'est quoi
la dolce vita la dol Vita c'est
l'histoire de l'ancour c'est la maison
de Monsieur pin que tout le monde
connaît de plus 40 ans et qu'il est
venue ici dans la Sicile qu' avait 17
ans au début il dor même sur la rue et
après il s cré tout ça tout seul il a
travaillé dur pour tout Paris il s'est
installé ici tout le monde il a bien
aimé il a bien aimé sa pizza en plus ici
c'est le restaurant dans Pourquoi comme
vous savez on
laol quand il était petite il venait ici
à manger on a fait sa pizza que c'est la
Nicola nelka effectivement qu' était
très répouté ici voilà justement P vous
en par il est d il y a 2 ans mais
pourtant la dolti est toujours là vous
avez voulu continuer touours oui on fait
tout pour que ça marche toujours pour un
souvenir de notre père c'est quoi la
force de la dolché c'est fait maison
c'est tout fait maison c'est tout fait
maison les produits sont tous de qualité
c'est pour ça on se lève très tôt pour
faire les courses à rangis voilà et du
frais du frais frais voilà alors
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
manger nous pour goûter les pizzas de la
dol ben moi je vous conseille franchaise
si le crtin ou sinon si la crème fraîche
il y en a Nicolas n voilà franpp il fait
très beau il fait très chaud est-ce
qu'on peut s'installer en terrasse oui
allez-y madame
[Musique]
super voilà la franchaise pour vous
parfait merci
beaucoup
en quelques bouché on comprend que le
Conseil était parfait la FR chaise c'est
15,50 € les pizza la DO c'est entre 11
et 17 € et vraiment je pense que vous
pouvez vous laisser tenter et moi je
vais
[Musique]
terminer
le site à 30 ans mais toujours son âme
d'enfant France Miniature porte bien son
nom vous le voyez autour de moi c'est la
France en miniature le château de
Versailles 117 maquettes sur 5 hectares
Marianne bonjour bonjour France
Miniature au départ ce sont deux
personnes c'est bien ça au départ France
Miniature c'est deux passionnés
effectivement qui réalisent leurs rêves
en ouvrant sur ce territoire un espace
sur 5 hectares qui représente toute la
France en miniature ces deux messieurs
c'était un passionné de monuments de
patrimoine et un de modèle réduit et de
train et tous les deux ont créé ce
concept très original et unique donc il
a 30 ans toujours ouvert ça plaît
qu'est-ce qui plaît justement au public
ce qui plaît au public ici c'est qu'il y
en a vraiment pour tous les âges on est
dans un joli jardin avec des paysages
qui sont très agréable il plaît au
public parce que quand on est tout petit
qu'on a 3 ou 4 ans tout est à hauteur
d'u et quand on est un adulte qui a déjà
voyagé ou pas on repère des monuments
emblématiques des châteaux des
cathédrales qu'on a peut-être déjà vu ou
qu'on a envie d'aller visiter et c'est
un un vrai lieu de partage d'expérience
et de de visite en famille ou entre amis
est-ce que depuis 30 ans on trouve
toujours les mêmes monuments où le parc
se renouvelle pour faire venir aussi les
les éan courtois Linois franilien un peu
plus régulièrement alors il y a une
petite évolution sur le sur la carte de
France certaines maquettes qui avaient
pour certain pas très bien vieillis ont
été remplacé ou restauré on a aussi
agrémenté le parcours avec des espaces
interactifs et ludiques pour permettre
aux plus jeunes de s'amuser avec le
décor donc c'est un parc en en
perpétuelle évolution où on apporte
chaque année des nouveaux contenus soit
pédagogiques soit plus ludique parce
qu'on peut jouer il y a des y a des on
peut jouer il y a des attractions qui
sont très familiales des attractions en
pleinir des attractions couvertes tout à
chaque fois en lien avec le décor le
patrimoine et et la France 200000
visiteurs chaque année c'était encore le
cas vous espérez que ce soit encore le
cas la saison prochaine on espère rester
dans ces tendan là on ouvre le parc au
printemps au mois d'avril jusqu'au mois
de novembre et en général effectivement
ce ce sont les fréquentations qu'on
annonce s'il vous reste encore un peu de
temps et que vous souhaitez vous poser
un peu et l'ENC gorge de lieux pour se
balader et
[Musique]
contempler
tout près de France Miniature et encore
plus de la commanderie des Templiers la
coulé vertes vous attend table pour se
restaurer ban pour se retrouver herbe
pour se reposer c'est le plus grand
espace de la commune 22 haar de
verdure je vous propose qu'on se quitte
ici après cette journée bien chargée je
vais profiter et de l'air qui circule et
de la vue et l'encour a encore plein de
secrets à vous révéler alors
laissez-vous
[Musique]
tenter